welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston who is the big dog in the MCU
these days is it a Hulk is it a god a
demon a human with Godly Powers a Nexus
being whatever that is or a robot with a
ball cap well as we look ahead from
Marvel base 4 to phase five and this
universe is suddenly flooded with
enhanced freaks with a range of power
sets including the latest mutant Namor
whom Ryan googler just claimed could
beat Thor and even beat up Hulk if he
was close enough to the water we just
really need to revisit our MCU our
ranking is Ryan googly right how has the
hierarchy of power in the Marvel
Universe changed and is the Rock at the
top of it I think he's contractually at
the top of every Power hierarchy in the
past been trying to rank Marvel
characters by power I looked at the
qualities the Marvel website uses when
assessing characters relative power in
the comics durability energy fighting
intelligence speed and strength but I
don't think those really line up to how
characters are depicted in the MCU so
instead I Define power in three ways one
the ability to shape the reality of
others two the ability to overwhelm
others in conflict and three how hard it
is to kill them now yes I can hear you
pacifist saying there's something to be
said for soft power like intelligence
social skills teamwork really I think
all that's covered by the ability to
shape the reality of others you know
like the ability to make friends and
influence people or really the ability
to say screw all that I'm gonna banish
you to a pocket Dimension we should also
remember that the MCU is not a single
elimination tournament where individual
wins or losses dictate your ranking it's
really a rotating League of Fighters who
run into each other then team up then
rematch realign there are overall
statuses are cost instantly shifting
based on the narrative circumstances
kind of like MTV's The Challenge like
bananas can say he's the all-time champ
but we all remember when CT turn him
into a backpack so in the MCU it really
helps to sort all the rankings into six
overall tiers tier one Terence tier two
enhanced tier three demigods tier four
Gods to your five Nexus beans into your
six Cosmic entities starting with tier
one terens so at the bottom of all this
is our average normal powered humans you
got your Nick Fury Maria Hill happy
Hogan Christine Palmer Darcy MJ Everett
Ross as well as the skilled fighters who
are harder to kill yet still killable
Natasha Romanov Elena bilova Clint
Barton Laura Barton Kate Bishop
killmonger before the heart-shaped derb
and Zemo now Sharon Carter Falls in here
though as the power broker she wields a
bit more influence than the others but
you know I've ranked Nick Fury spycraft
over her art friends I'd also throw Ned
leads somewhere in here even though it
turns out he's a sorcerer so who knows
and right at the top of these Terran
Fighters are Daredevil and Echo because
there are other senses they're
definitely dialed up to pseudo
superhuman levels all these terrans are
strong but definitely very killable and
and specifically they are limited by the
governments the media and the corporate
powers on planet Earth but Define
organizations like that is our second
tier and the biggest tier on our list
the enhanced in its biggest year because
pretty much every mutant and Rogue
weirdo who got introduced in She-Hulk
fits into this category in the back of
the Winter Soldier Sam and Bucky refer
to these as Androids aliens and wizards
but this is also where we include people
with super suits super soldiers and all
these other nebulous enhanced pokes
whatever they are now at the lower end
of the steer is anyone with gear
upgrades Tony Stark Roadie Sam Wilson
Captain America Scott Lang Cassie Lang
hope Van Dyne Hank Pym Janet Van Dyne
Doc Ock Quentin Beck Adrian tombs the
wakandans whenever they use vibranium
Tech you know okay and I think we can
also group with these not just man-made
Tech but like Cosmic or mystical attack
when it is part of the character's
identity as opposed to just something
they pick up and use once so like Shang
CHI with the 10 rings and Elsa with the
Bloodstone now A step above the
Gearheads but still within the enhanced
tier are our super soldiers Steve Rogers
Bucky Barnes Red Guardian John Walker
the flag Smashers Captain Carter 838 and
it wasn't confirmed but Kingpin and
Hawkeye definitely seem to have super
soldier's strength and durability
wouldn't surprise me that that guy had
been juicing now these super soldiers
roughly have the same fighting skill as
the aliens of the MCU many of which come
with cybernetic enhancements or
biological advantages Groot rocket
Gamora nebula Drax mantis yandoo an
average skrull Warrior an average Cree
Warrior the black order Adam Warlock or
really anyone with a symbiote attached
so like Venom Carnage I would put them
all here also somewhere on this tier are
those enhanced by freak accidents or
Supernatural curses Peter Parker Norman
Osborne Green Goblin Electro Sandman man
thing werewolf by Knight blade most
mutants fall here as well mutants
probably the most diverse class of all
these with their powers ranging all over
but already we have Billy and Tommy
maximoff Wolverine's gonna be showing up
Deadpool storm Cyclops Magneto now Omega
Level mutants like Phoenix will rank
much higher here like god tier but now
we come to the most debated part of this
the hulks because in the comics Hulk is
supposed to have Limitless range like it
could be a world breaker but in the MCU
Hulk has really been de-powered he's
been knocked out more than once so I
think here on this tier would go the
Hulk family Bruce Banner and everyone
who has used his blood yamil botsky
Abomination the leader Hulk Todd Jen
Walters Bruce Banner himself but we will
come back to Jen Walters if
our Channel you've heard us mention
Helix mattresses which is where we all
go to sleep after wearing ourselves out
making videos all day and where we dream
up our most helpless theories we love
Helix and that's why we're so stoked to
hear that the same people who make Helix
mattresses are leaving the bedroom and
entering our Waking Life with a new
company called all form which makes
custom sofas all4 makes it easy to pick
a sofa that's the right size color shape
and fabric for you and your home they've
got everything from armchairs and love
seats to eight seat sectionals all forms
furniture is made from 90 recycled
materials and it's built to last we're
talking hardwood frames high grade
cushions and performance Fabrics that
are stain resistant durable and soft
everything is manufactured in the US at
a family-owned facility so you can feel
good about the purchase you're making
every time you use it your custom sofa
ships to your home for free in just
three to seven days and you can assemble
it yourself easily once it arrives new
Rockstar's editor John got a brown
leather armchair and an ottoman from all
form and absolutely loves them he dreams
about editing the break room while
getting in a quick nap in his comfrey
chair as a a nice chair they have a 100
day trial so you can get more than three
months to make sure that you love it and
if you don't they'll pick it up for you
and you will get a full refund keep your
sofa and you'll get a forever warranty
literally food red Burr we love the
all-born furniture that we've gotten and
we think you will too to find your
perfect sofa check out allforum.com new
rockstars all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our audience at
allforum.com new rockstars then we
arrive at the people enhanced but by
Cosmic radiation like Kamala Khan
Through the Bengals Cameron Monica Rambo
and Carol Danvers now when Carol Danvers
goes binary she's pretty unbeatable but
I would still say it's all brute
strength you can't really break out of
this reality or go full God status I
actually would say Maria Rambo from 838
is stronger than her along with the a38
Illuminati members Reed Richards Charles
Xavier and Black Bolt now the Androids
also fall within this enhanced tier
because they're typically a mix of
man-made Ai and Tech and all very
killable Vision white Vision Ultron Zola
and Modoc I would place at the top of
this enhanced tier the sorcerers Doctor
Strange Wong mordo AG of the hardness
Wanda maximoff ebony Ma and Cleo because
they have access at least to Cosmic
forces and multiversal Magic that the
other enhanced Fighters don't so in a
bite between sorcerer Supreme morto and
Carol Danvers yeah I'd give that to
mordo on to tier three the demigods
these are Offspring or creations of the
Gods who carry out the God's Will and
can temporarily level up to God's status
so you got your ass Guardians Thor Loki
Valkyrie lady sip Heimdall hella you
also got your eternals both the ones of
Earth and of other planets like Titan
like Thanos and arrows Peter Quill is
the son of a Celestial and Hercules son
of Zeus all the characters I mentioned
typically live very long lives seems
like they can hold Infinity Stones or at
least handle very powerful Cosmic
technology and other people see them as
Gods but there is like a level above
them and I would put Gore the god
butcher here but only when he has the
necro sword since he can kill Gods with
it kind of makes sense that he would be
one level beneath it but I also include
on this tier the avatars of gods Moon
Knight is powered by konshu Scarlet
Scarab who's powered by Taurus black
panther who's powered by boss and Namor
who's powered by the Mayan deity cuckoo
con this this is why I think Ryan
coogler is right to say no more could
could keep up with Thor and probably
beat Hulk at least the way Hulk is
depicted in the MCU because the way the
rules of power work in this Cinematic
Universe characters like Moon Knight and
not more have a pretty powerful
Advantage also I want to add that I
think anyone with one functional
infinity stone that they can use and
handle Rises to demigod status
automatically tier 4 are the gods these
are the semi-immortal Heavenly beings
who use Mortals in lower tiers as their
Champions they often don't get involved
themselves so this includes Odin and
Zeus Bost kukukan the celestials ego
who's also Celestial konshu Ahmet to our
ex the whole iniad as well as the gods
of omnipotent City and I think anyone
with multiple Infinity Stones becomes
God status so Thanos in the first half
of infinity War now this tier wood also
include slightly more abstract Gods like
Galactus dormammu kathon who's an elder
god and the character of Love who at the
end of love and thunder was a goddess
spawned by eternity now I think Mephisto
would fit in this category since he has
the same kind of mythological Roots as
other gods but we'll see how powerful he
ends up being in the MC tier five are
the Nexus beans these are individuals
who through technology or magic
transcend reality to become multiversal
beings who can manipulate the laws of
nature making them pretty tricky to kill
but they can still die anyone who uses
all six Infinity Stones at once reaches
this tier but only temporarily and at a
cost this is the tier where we see he
who remains in the TBA Kang the
Conqueror in all of its variants also
Scarlet Witch or Dr
dreamwalk Loki in his variants when they
are in the TVA Ultron infinity and what
if an argument could be made for fourth
wall breakers like She-Hulk and Deadpool
being Nexus beans but ultimately
she-hulk's edits were overruled by Kevin
and I would call the Kevin robot a Nexus
being but only in the context of the
reality of the seahold finale so our
final tier tier VI Cosmic entities these
are the multiversal near abstract beings
that don't really die but because they
represent Concepts Thor 11 Thunder
depicted these as shrines in the chamber
at the center of the universe eternity
The Living Tribunal The Watcher the
celestial one above all presumably the
leader of the celestial's death Eon and
infinity now I also interpret Kevin to
be on this level since that robot is
really a stand-in for Kevin feige in the
whole studio he leads so there we have
it six tears of power and I'm sure it'll
never change you can follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter hey boss you
can follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you